un jour Harrison dis-moi je vais faire
ma tournée avec les Beatles et et et il
s'en va il voulait vous avec Patty bail
vous partez à Saint-Tropez et il vous
fait des pétards qui vous roulent pour 3
semaines de pétard boîte de tampax plan
c'est une star de l'enderground que nous
recevons ce soir très heureux de vous
voir d'abord très heureux de vous voir
vivante parce que vous êtes pas passé
loin voilà Zouzou la twisteuse donc
c'est vrai que la mode est un petit peu
en ce moment aux égérie
60 et 70 on a eu Dany ici on a eu
Marie-France on a eu Jenny Belair on a
eu Ingrid Caven Jean-Jacques Schul enfin
c'est vrai qu'il y a un revival comme ça
de ces années 60-70 on peut dire votre
âge non ah oui
60 dans un mois voilà alors vous sortez
un livre donc Zouzou vous racontez votre
histoire s'appelle jusqu'à l'aube en
collaboration avec Olivier Nico c'est
chez Flammarion voilà
une compil qui s'appelle l'intégrale il
y a le livre il y a la compil il y a le
Centre Pompidou non mais c'est énorme
plus personne n'a entendu parler de 20
ans et d'un seul coup tu as un bouquin
une compile une responsive à Beaubourg
tous vos films du 23 janvier au 9
février tous vos films à Bobo ouais
certains seul coup ça tombe sur vous
comme ça vous savez que c'est très
violent quand même non alors on va en
revenir au livre et d'abord évidemment
quand on a un livre comme le vôtre la
première chose qu'on fait c'est qu'on
regarde les photos évidemment donc on va
d'abord regarder les photos et après on
parlera du texte
[Musique]
Zouzou quelques photographies tirées du
livre qui s'appelle jusqu'à l'aube qui
paraît chez Flammarion voilà alors votre
prénom c'est Daniel sarlet vous êtes né
à Blida en Algérie absolument et alors
vos parents s'étaient rencontrés dans un
dancing qui s'appelait le paradis
c'était pendant la guerre voilà votre
mère était danseuse votre mère était
militaire c'est une histoire absolument
géniale et puis voilà lui il rentre en
métropole et puis vous et votre mère
et une petite fille et puis voilà et
quand vous arrivez vous avez rendez-vous
sur un quai de gare à Marseille et il
est pas là et il est pas là et vous
dites dans votre bouquin que votre mère
est passée directement du Paradis
j'adore ces histoires parce que les
chansons populaires tu sais voilà moi
aussi j'adore alors quand vous étiez
petit vous étiez déjà star quand même
vous regardiez dans les miroirs tout ça
que vous voyez
vous étiez une excellente élève
excellente comment ça a passé son bac à
13 ans et demi ça laisse rêveur non
c'est vrai et malheureusement voilà vous
commencez un petit peu à traîner Zouzou
avec les blousons noirs de la bestille
le matin vous quittez la maison à
billets normalement et puis dans votre
sac il y a un cuir voilà voilà un jean
débute il y a tout ce qu'il faut
un épisode assez dur dans votre bouquin
à passer tant de là-dessus mais qui peut
être explique beaucoup de choses pour la
suite c'est le vous allez en vacances à
Juan-les-Pins vous faites violer
et lorsqu'il est extraordinaire c'est
que cette maison ou a lieu le viol c'est
maison près de Grasse a été retrouvé par
Jean-Philippe Smet qui n'était pas
encore ou qui commençait à être Johnny
Hallyday absolument et Carlos qui avait
encore un nom à l'époque à coucher
dehors que je ne citerai pas non plus
j'allais à Juan-les-Pins chez mon cousin
qui était qui avait deux ans de plus que
moi il y avait cet endroit où Johnny
passait tous les soirs et donc
évidemment c'était mon grand frère
et donc Johnny et Carlos vous aide à
retrouver la maison vous avez été violée
monte une expédition punitive quoi avec
Johnny qui tout de suite y va Carlos qui
était là aussi et puis pas une dizaine
d'autres personnes pour retrouver ces
mecs qui m'ont vraiment laissé leur dans
fausser à moitié morte et voilà quoi
voilà et c'est Jean-Paul Goude
l'excellent Jean-Paul Goude le créateur
de création mec génial un grand artiste
qui vous a réconcilié avec la gente
masculine avec l'amour avec beaucoup de
précautions alors vous avez été
mannequin pour lui mais aussi pour des
grandes marques vous avez
même être mannequin vedette de
Saint-Laurent pour sa toute première
maison de couture et malheureusement
j'avais beaucoup de mal à faire les
trois huit quoi parce que
fallait que je me pointe parce qu'il y
avait une pointeuse en plus et en blouse
hop il faut aussi le machin truc moi qui
détest
j'avais le vieux maquillage de la veille
le peu qui restait parce qu'elle est pas
beaucoup et j'allais dormir chez
Saint-Laurent alors lui ça ne gênait pas
vraiment
de temps en temps laisser la dormir elle
dort celle-là et Pierre Berger ça l'a un
peu ennuyé
quand même voilà
la vérité c'est que vous passiez vos
nuits
chez Régine et d'ailleurs
c'est comme ça que vous avez fini par
tromper Jean-Paul avec son meilleur ami
exact j'ai honte pardonnez-moi alors
voilà là vous devenez Zouzou la
twisteuse parce que à cause de ça voilà
parce que
[Musique]
il y avait ça et vous commencez à danser
voilà d'un seul coup moi moi je m'en
souviens j'étais tout petit mais quand
même le twist explose ah oui et puis il
y avait surtout une bande des mecs de
West Side Story qui était arrivé à Paris
et qui avait amené cette danse quoi je
l'ai dit donc on était ah oui non il y
avait la bande
wESTIM il y avait la bande des
photographes de Paris Match lequel Paris
Match a écrit si Toulouse-Lautrec
l'avait connu il n'aurait peinte sous le
nom de Zouzou la twisteuse et ce nom
vous est resté voilà la Goulue 61 voilà
alors évidemment alors il y a un truc
que je voulais savoir quand même ah là
vous allez me répondre il y a un moment
vous dites que vous allez dans un
endroit la gavik tenu par Jean-Marie
rivière et kedith Piaf est là et qui
Édith Piaf fait tourner un peu en
bourrique les gens et à un moment elle
fait tourner en bourrique le petit-fils
le grand dites-vous président de la
République c'est qui le petit-fils du
général ça veut dire que le petit-fils
du général de Gaulle quand il était dans
cette boîte
animée par Jean-Marie rivière et Piaf un
jour l'oblige à se déguiser en femme et
ensuite à faire un strip-tease énorme
donc voilà donc voilà ce qui se passe la
Xavier on a vu ce qui se passait chez
Régine avec le twist ou vous allez
évidemment chez Castel il a évidemment
vous devenez amis c'est extraordinaire
la vie de Zouzou vous devenez ami avec
George Harrison et avec sa femme tatie
Boys et alors c'est très rigolo vous
raconter ça c'est d'ailleurs les vrai
quand il y a une part en vacances
dis-moi je vais faire ma tournée avec
les Beatles et et il s'en va il voulait
vous avec Patty boy vous partez à
Saint-Tropez et il vous fait des pétards
qui vous roulent pour 3 semaines de
pétard boîte de tampax plane
voilà et quand vous arrivez à
Saint-Tropez elles ont les pétards
rouler par Jack Harrison j'ai quand même
énorme et bien fait la machine
et vous en offrez un desserts on est sur
le port et on nous demande nos papiers
d'identité d'abord mais je suis avec
Patty et sa sœur qui comprennent rien et
Pâquier on est tous avec notre joint
quoi et donc
il y en a un qui me dit mais qu'est-ce
que vous fumez là je dis le tabatures
tout de suite les cigarettes turques et
j'ai dit vous en voulez une mec il me
dit oui je dis j'attrape le paquet je
suis en offre une OK et puis avec Patty
on se dit hop je lui fais signe qui vaut
mieux prendre de la tangente on se tire
et on repasse une heure après pour voir
et on voit le mec assis devant chez
Sénéquier
avec son pote les deux les yeux
dis donc il y a les CRS qui cherchent
partout
voilà alors la vie de joujou dans ce
bouquin c'est absolument extraordinaire
je le conseille après vous rencontrez
Brian Jones le Rolling Stone le plus
extraordinaire le blanc avec les douches
jusque là le mythique des Stone le
fondateur du groupe le pot et vous vous
installez voilà chez lui à Chelsea donc
là vous trompez un petit peu Michel
votre vie
c'est pas les cigarettes turques oui
j'avais pourtant j'étais une grande
idéaliste je rêvais du grand amour pour
la vie et c'est marrant quand même il y
a des embûches tout le temps sur mon
chemin
pour moi c'est ça effectivement après
mais au début j'ai pas une seconde sur
la tête quand vous le voyez c'est au
bilboquet il veut monter
changer vos pulls dans les chiottes et
après évidemment
alors vous trompez Michel bon alors les
femmes les les fans vous détestent
Chelsea devant la maison il y a des
filles qui toute la journée toute la
journée [__] de françaises [__] de
France
et voilà et vous faites vos débuts dans
la chanson faites le début de la chanson
à ce moment-là
grâce à Pierre Bénichou alors bon là il
y a la rupture avec Bryan Jones un jour
il vous met un morceau et en écoutant
les paroles vous dites il veut plus de
moi c'est génial
et vous découvrez à ce moment-là que
vous êtes accroché au speed et après ça
commence alors là bon grave quoi
descendre dans la dos
les speed l'héroïne forcément parce que
vous faites des trucs là vous tournez
l'amour l'après-midi avec avec remarque
un film important vous faites sauter par
Warren Betty c'est pas une importance
parce qu'on est nombreux hein
il a vu votre photo il a vu votre photo
un jour dans un avion dans elle voit
votre photo je vais me taper cette
gonzesse il arrive et vous croyais que
c'est Nicole sonne que vous avez monté
un chat à New York pas du tout c'est une
idée à lui alors maintenant sérieusement
les yeux dans les yeux c'est vrai qu'il
y a une très grosse [__] Warren Betty
non mais excusez-moi mais non c'est de
l'histoire qu'on fait là non non non en
fait de l'archéologie de la modernité là
il peut avoir un petit corps oui oui
est-ce qu'il avait un petit corps par
rapport à sa [__] tout était absolument
normal quoi rien d'extraordinaire alors
comment il va se succès parce que moi on
a toujours dit la discussion
quand j'ai vu quand même un beau mec
avec intelligent et en plus ça pas été
comme ça j'ai pris tout le temps qu'il
fallait pour bon ben voilà là maintenant
on va pas finir bon voilà c'est
l'Hérault on est en plein alors là c'est
l'histoire de c'est l'époque du club
l'aventure dernier nous en a parlé ici
Marc Porel tout ça c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque vous vous êtes quand même c'est
énorme ça vous êtes à 7 g par jour et on
se demande comment vous êtes là parce
que 7 g par jour c'est beaucoup et vous
commencez à dîner vous bah oui parce que
il faut bien se payer ça coûte quand
même 30 briques par mois la plaisanterie
personne donc 7 grammes par jour 30
briques par mois vous commencez à dîner
après vous commencez à braquer les
dealers et quand vous allez vous faire
soigner le traitement de substitution
qu'on vous donne à l'époque il équivaut
à deux grammes par jour donc
voilà exactement donc qu'est-ce qui se
passe vous partez aux Antilles vous
partez à Saint-Bart d'ailleurs à un
moment tout le monde vous croit vous
croit mort un jour il y a nicoleson qui
vous appelle parce que Bernardo chercher
zouzous partout voilà donc
à Paris pendant deux ans vous êtes clean
et puis vous recommencez à dire c'est
c'est très dur vous allez vous êtes
descendu bah vous avez fait de la prison
vous êtes retrouvé en train de vendre
des journaux de RMI dans la rue dans le
métro dans le métro dans le métro parce
que ah oui il fait froid mais c'est le
moment le plus difficile pour vous ça a
été attendez c'est pas gai
c'est très très dur mais en même temps
je veux dire moi j'ai toujours vu je me
suis toujours dit il faut essayer de
j'avais toujours l'impression que
j'allais en sortir qui allait quelque
chose à l'espace quoi ça allait pas se
terminer comme ça clocharde et
aujourd'hui comment ça va alors ah bah
ça va ça va super bien vraiment bien
mais maintenant je suis en pleine forme
quoi quand tout le monde le sache j'ai
vaincu et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu